other news tonight a local man fighting
to survive three days after police say
he was hurt in a crash caused by a
driver who was under the influence and
without a valid license it happened
Sunday night near MLK and Cheyenne while
he was riding his motorcycle up in North
Las Vegas Sasha Loftus spoke with his
family tonight as they worked to raise
awareness joining us now live from UMC
tonight with more
political condition here at UMC tonight
his family tells me this has been a
horrible experience and it's something
they believe didn't have to happen
he's just in a lot of pain right now
Michael javon's family says he's doing
everything he can to stay alive he's
always fighting for what's Best in his
life and right now he's fighting for his
recovery the 26 year old army officer
was seriously hurt while riding his
motorcycle Sunday night on Martin Luther
King near Cheyenne in North Las Vegas
police say 28-year-old Oscar Sanchez
Vasquez was reportedly driving without a
license and showed signs of impairment
when he pulled in front of him and
caused the crash he got hit and flew 20
feet from his motorcycle and hit a pole
his sisters Catherine and Audrey say
they want everyone to be aware of the
dangers of driving Under the Influence
People shouldn't do it it only takes
what 20 30 bucks to take an Uber but as
traumatic as this experience has been
they say it's comforting to know others
will step up to help it's something
we're forever grateful for as his family
as his sisters to know that my brother
is taken care of by his unit by his
friends and by his family as they do
everything they can to come together and
help Michael push through to make a full
recovery from something no one ever
expected it just hurts my heart
police say Sanchez Vasquez faces
multiple charges including DUI resulting
in substantial bodily harm failure to
yield and driving without a valid
license now the family does have a
GoFundMe up right now to help with
medical expenses if you'd like to help
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now